♪
>> WHEN I FIRST WAS ELECTED VICE
PRESIDENT WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA,
THE MILITARY SAT US DOWN TO LET
US KNOW WHAT THE GREATEST
THREATS FACING AMERICA WERE, THE
GREATEST PHYSICAL THREATS.
THIS IS NOT A JOKE.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE JOINT
CHIEFS TOLD US THE GREATEST
THREAT FACING AMERICA WAS?
GLOBAL WARMING.
>> CLIMATE CHANGE IS A THREAT
BUT THE PRESIDENT IS LOOKING AT
IT AT A MUCH BROADER ANGLE THAN
I AM.
I'M LOOKING AT IT FROM A
STRICTLY MILITARY STANDPOINT
FROM.
A STRICTLY MILITARY STANDPOINT,
I'M PUTTING CHINA, RUSSIA UP
THERE.
>> Bret: WELL THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE JOINT CHIEFS MARK MILLEY
FEELING THE NEED, PERHAPS, TO
QUALIFY OR CLARIFY THE
PRESIDENT'S STATEMENT ON
WEDNESDAY AS YOU HEARD HE
DELIVERED IN ENGLAND.
THE CHAIRMAN JOINT CHIEFS WENT
ON TO SAY THE NUMBER ONE
MILITARY THREAT AS WE GO FORWARD
IS CHINA BUT HE CONSIDERS RUSSIA
A MAJOR COMPETITOR.
THIS AS, OBVIOUSLY, THE
PRESIDENT CONTINUES HIS EUROPEAN
TRIP.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL BEN
DOMENECH.
KATIE PAVLICH, AND HAROLD FORD
JR., FORMER TENNESSEE
CONGRESSMAN, CEO OF EMPOWERMENT
INCLUSION CAPITAL.
BEN, YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT.
>> Ben: WELL, OBVIOUSLY, I
DISPUTE PRESIDENT BIDEN'S NOTION
REGARDING CLIMATE CHANGE.
I'M VERY CURIOUS TO SEE A NUMBER
OF THINGS EMERGING FROM THIS G-7
SUMMIT.
INCLUDING, OF COURSE, THIS
MEETING WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN,
WHICH, UNFORTUNATELY, I THINK,
IS SET UP TO BE REALLY A COUP
FOR PUTIN IN SOME DIFFERENT
RESPECTS.
ALREADY GOT THE NORD STREAM
PIPELINE.
NOT GOING TO HAVE ANYTHING THAT
I THINK IN BELARUS.
YOU WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
RUSSIAN ACTORS WHETHER
GOVERNMENT-BACKED OR NOT EXTRACT
RANSOMWARE FROM COMPANIES AROUND
THE WORLD.
AND I THINK THAT YOU REALLY ARE
GOING TO SEE, YOU KNOW, IN THE
CONTINUED CRACKDOWN ON ANY KIND
OF DOMESTIC PUSHBACK AGAINST
PUTIN'S REGIME.
ESPECIALLY FROM ALEXI NAVALNY.
THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE AFTER
ALL OF THIS TALK OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION BEING SOFT ON
RUSSIA, YOU KNOW, THE OUTCOME
WHEN IT COMES TO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS ALMOST
CERTAINLY GOING TO BE SOME ANGRY
LANGUAGE OR SOME VERY STERN
TALKING TO FROM THE PRESIDENT I
DON'T REALLY EXPECT ANYTHING TO
COME OUT OF IT THAT IS GOING TO
ENCOURAGE ANY OF WHO BELIEVE
THAT AMERICA OUGHT TO BE PUSHING
BACK STRONGER AGAINST RUSSIAN
INFLUENCE.
>> Bret: WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
CHINA AND RUSSIA AND A LITTLE
BIT OF THE THREAT THAT IRAN
POSES.
THAT COME UP ON THIS HEARING ON
CAPITOL HILL IRAN DOCKING AND
DOING BUSINESS WITH VENEZUELA.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> ALLOWING THIS SHIP TO DOCK,
SIGNIFICANT TO ME ON MANY
DIFFERENT LEVELS.
IT WOULD BE THE FIRST TIME THAT
IRANIAN VESSELS HAVE MADE SUCH A
TRANSIT AND THE PRESIDENT IS
ALLOWING IRAN TO PROVIDE WEAPONS
TO THE REGION CAUSES ME GRAVE
CONCERN.
>> I AM ABSOLUTELY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PROLIFERATION OF
WEAPONS, ANY TYPE OF WEAPONS
IN -- IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD.
>> Bret: DEFENSE SECRETARY
THERE, KATIE?
>> Katie: WELL, THIS MOVE BY THE
IRANIANS TO GET EVEN CLOSER TO
THE UNITED STATES AND TO BUILD
THEIR ALLIANCE WITH VENEZUELA
AND USE AS TRANSFER POINT FOR
WEAPONS TO SOUTH AMERICA
CERTAINLY ISN'T A GESTURE OF
GOODWILL WHILE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS STILL
NEGOTIATING TRYING TO GET DOWN
TO THE WIRE ON SOME KIND OF
AGREEMENT TO GET BACK INTO THE
IRANIAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION MADE
THE ARGUMENT IF WE GOT BACK INTO
THE DEAL THAT IRAN WOULD IMPROVE
THEIR BEHAVIOR ON A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT FRONTS.
WE SAW THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
IN FACT, IRAN GOT MORE
AGGRESSIVE ONCE THEY WERE IN THE
NUCLEAR AGREEMENT.
WE ARE NOW SEEING THAT THE MORE
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
NEGOTIATES WITH THEM THE MORE
AGGRESSIVE THEY BECOME.
WHETHER THAT'S SENDING SHIPS TO
VENEZUELA FOR A WEAPONS TRANSFER
OR WHETHER THAT'S FUNDING HAMAS
TO WAGE A WAR AGAINST ISRAEL
THROUGH HAMAS.
WHETHER IT'S FINDING OTHER
PROXIES IN THE REGION LIKE THE
HOUTHIS AGAINST SAUDI ARABIA.
SO THIS CONCEPT OF OFFERING
IRANIANS A NUCLEAR AGREEMENT AND
HOPING IN RETURN THEY WILL
SOMEHOW CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR WE
HAVE SEEN THE OPPOSITE OF THAT
HAPPEN AND IT'S HAPPENING AS WE
SPEAK WHILE THEY ARE TRYING TO
NEGOTIATE SOME KIND OF
AGREEMENT.
>> Bret: HAROLD, CRITICS OF THE
PRESIDENT HAVE SAID THAT IRAN,
CHINA, RUSSIA, SEE SOFTNESS SO
THEY'RE ACTING IN VARIOUS
DIFFERENT WAYS TO CHALLENGE THAT
AT THE SAME TIME, ON THIS TRIP,
THE PRESIDENT HAS HAD SUCCESS IN
THE WORLD'S EYES, AT LEAST THIS
VACCINATION EFFORT AND
500 MILLION VACCINES THAT WAS
MATCHED JUST BEFORE THE SHOW
STARTED OF ANOTHER 500 MILLION
FROM THE G-7.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THE PRESIDENT.
>> AMERICA WILL BE THE ARSENAL
OF VACCINES IN OUR FIGHT AGAINST
COVID-19.
JUST AS AMERICA WAS THE ARSENAL
OF DEMOCRACY DURING WORLD WAR
II.
OUR VACCINE DONATIONS DON'T
INCLUDE PRESSURE FOR FAVORS OR
POTENTIAL CONCESSIONS.
WE'RE DOING THIS TO SAVE LIVES,
TO END THIS PANDEMIC.
THAT'S IT.
PERIOD.
WE HAVE THE LOWEST NUMBER OF
DAILY DEATHS SIPS THE FIRST DAY
OF THIS PANDEMIC.
OUR ECONOMY IS REBOUNDING.
OUR VACCINATION PROGRAM HAS
ALREADY SAVED TENS OF THOUGH
SANDS OF LIVES.
>> Bret: OBVIOUSLY THE WHITE
HOUSE IS TOUTING THAT AS A
GLOBAL EFFORT LED BY THE U.S.
HAROLD.
>> Harold: LOOK, THAT'S AN
EXAMPLE OF -- THANKS FOR HAVING
ME ON.
IT'S AN EXAMPLE OF OUR SOFT
POWER.
THIS PRESIDENT WAS DIRECT ATTACK
ALSO, I THINK, AT CHINA, DIRECT
LINE OF ATTACK AT CHINA AS HE
SAID WE ARE NOT LOOKING FOR
CONCESSIONS OR FAVORS FROM THOSE
NATIONS THAT WE SEEK TO HELP.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE HAD A LITTLE
DIFFERENT OPINION.
I FOUND SOME OF THE ANALYSIS
INTERESTING WITH SOME OF THE
OTHER PANELISTS.
MY PERSPECTIVE IS SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT.
I THINK THIS EFFORT TO BUILD, TO
STRENGTHEN OUR MULTILATERAL
APPROACH OR SHOULD SAY
STRENGTHEN RELATIONSHIPS WITH
ALLIES.
BUILD EVEN STRONGER ONES WITH
COUNTRIES WE ARE SEEKING TO HAVE
A BETTER RELATIONSHIP WITH AS WE
ENTER THE ENDING OF THIS COLD
WAR WITH CHINA I THINK IS A VERY
SMART THING.
THE WORLD IS A MESSY PLACE, IT'S
A DANGEROUS PLACE, IT ALWAYS HAS
BEEN.
I'M RELIEVED A BIT BY THE
EXPERIENCE THIS PRESIDENT BRINGS
AND I HOPE THAT HE AND SECRETARY
BLINKEN AND SECRETARY AUSTIN
WON'T BE AFRAID TO PULL AND USE
EVERY LEVER AND YOU HAVE TO BE
ENCOURAGED WATCH HIM USE THE
SOFT POWER LEVER AS MUCH AS
THEY'RE.
WITHOUT QUESTION THE DOMINANT
ORGANIZING THEME FOR OUR FOREIGN
POLICY OVER THE NEXT 5, 10, 5
YEARS, MY KIDS YEARS IN MIDDLE
SCHOOL HIGH SCHOOL AND COLLEGE
WILL BE HOW WE COMPETE AND BEAT
CHINA.
THAT'S WHAT I HEARD FROM OUR
MILITARY LEADERS TODAY IN
CONGRESS.
AND THAT'S WHAT I CONTINUE TO
HEAR FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
HIS TEAM AS WELL.
>> Bret: WE SHOULD POINT OUT
THERE WAS ALSO AN ATTACK ON
BAGHDAD ON THE STATE DEPARTMENT
COMPOUND AT THE AIRPORT JUST
LAST NIGHT WITH A DRONE.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR THE
CULPRI